[Music]
it's appeared in dozens of movies and
had a starring role in New York City
skyline for generations now the iconic
Chrysler Building is going up for sale
the Chrysler Building is just the
grandest of them all it's up there in
the air it has these you know wonderful
shapes of the silvery top which is
really unrivaled it's just one of those
buildings that you can't imagine New
York City without the 89 year old
skyscraper is one of the leading
examples of Art Deco architecture and
1046 feet it became the world's tallest
building but only after builders
installed a 125 foot stainless steel
spire atop the structure that title only
lasted 11 months when its larger
neighbor the Empire State Building open
its doors just a few blocks away sale
price estimates for the famed Chrysler
Building vary but it's majority owners
the Abu Dhabi Investment Council hoped
to recoup the 800 million dollars it
paid for the building back in 2008 but
buyer beware the land beneath the
building is owned by New York's Cooper
Union School and the lease last year
came to thirty two point five million
dollars on top of that the new owners
will also have to compete for tenants
with newer buildings that offer much
more up-to-date amenities ain't that the
truth if I had 800 million dollars I'd
buy this beautifully most beautiful bike
I just adore in New York City with a tow
: oh that's my belly yeah cool